2 me demandez pas de prédire je ne
prédis jamais rien et prédire quelque
chose sur une maladie nouvelle n'est
jamais sérieux c'est pas raisonnable
on connaît pas ce que peut devenir cette
maladie en sais rien ce qu'il faut c'est
être armé pour répondre pour répondre
progressivement avec calme avec
optimisme parce que le pessimisme tu les
malades
donc c'est ce qu'on apprend ce qu'on
apprenait en médecine il faut toujours
prendre la branche la plus optimiste
parce que même il ya deux mille ans d
hippocrate disais ça il faut commencer
par chalmé rassurer les malades leur
donner de l'espoir et c'est pas une
crime donner de l'espoir aux gens quand
on pense qu'il ya l'espoir qu'il faut le
faire